guck mal hier der antigen schnelltest
der hat eine sensitivität von 80 und
eine spezifität sogar von 98 prozent ist
ja wahnsinnig sicher das stimmt ja quasi
jedes ergebnis warum das nicht so ist ja
sogar überhaupt nicht stimmt sie sogar
zum super spacer werden könnten trotzdem
wollen wir in diesem video mal auf den
grund gehen
[Musik]
die begriffe sensitivität und spezifität
die verbinden wir ja irgendwie mit der
genauigkeit eines tests und das ist auch
im großen und ganzen richtig aber warum
gibt es dann diese zwei werte
sensitivität und spezifität das liegt
daran dass man ja einerseits wissen will
ob ein test zum beispiel alle
infizierten auch erkennt ihm also nichts
durch die lappen geht andererseits aber
auch wissen will ob denn alle die der
test als infiziert erkennt auch wirklich
infiziert sind also dass der test keine
fehlalarme produziert
und genau hier kommen die beiden
begriffe ins spiel
die sensitivität oder empfindlichkeit
gibt an wie viel prozent der test bei
tatsächlich infizierten die infektion
auch erkennt die spezifität dagegen gibt
an wie viel prozent der test tatsächlich
nicht infizierte auch als nicht
infiziert erkennt bei der sensitivität
geht es also darum keine infektion zu
übersehen weil der spezifität geht es
darum keine fehlalarme zu produzieren
das lka hat diesen zusammenhang in einer
grafik dargestellt
das beispiel sensitivität 80 prozent und
spezifität 98 prozent heißt also dass
der test 20 prozent der tatsächlich
infizierten verpasst und bei zwei
prozent einen fehlalarm auslösen
das klingt ja insgesamt nicht nach sehr
viel 2% fehlalarme damit könnte man doch
leben doch so ist es in der realität
nicht wie hoch tatsächlich die
verpassten infektionen beziehungsweise
die fehlalarme sind hängt entscheidend
davon ab bei wenig den test machen und
dazu schauen wir uns mal zwei
verschiedene szenarien
szenario 1 wir testen 10.000 menschen in
einer zeit in der die infektion relativ
stark verbreitet ist sagen wir die
infektionsrate beträgt zehn prozent also
1000 menschen der 10.000 sind
tatsächlich akut infiziert gott sei dank
sind wir in der bevölkerung weit davon
entfernt der anteil aktiver infektionen
wird auf ca 0,2 prozent geschätzt im
szenario 2 testen wir wieder 10.000
menschen aber nicht tausend menschen wie
in szenario eins sondern nur fünf von
den 10.000 sind infiziert schauen wir
uns zuerst das szenario eins an bei dem
relativ viele menschen unter den
getesteten tatsächlich auch infiziert
sind
wir wissen von den 10.000 sind 1000
infiziert das heißt auch 9000 sind nicht
infiziert die sensitivität des tests
beträgt 80 prozent das heißt 80 prozent
oder 800 menschen von den 1000
infizierten werden vom test auch als
solche erkannt werden also richtig als
positiv erkannt 20 prozent oder 200
menschen bekommen dagegen ein negatives
ergebnis werden also fälschlicherweise
nicht als infiziert erkannt bekommen ein
falsch negatives ergebnis
auf der anderen seite die nicht
infizierten
9000 sind nicht infiziert bei einer
spezifität von 98 bekommen auch 98
prozent davon also 8820 menschen ein
negatives testergebnis also richtig
negativ bei 2 prozent aber schlägt der
test an obwohl sie gar nicht infiziert
sind zwei prozent von 9000 sind 180 also
180 menschen die gar nicht infiziert
sind bekommen ein positives ein falsch
positives testergebnis okay und jetzt
wollen sie natürlich wissen wenn sie ein
positives testergebnis bekommen wie hoch
ist dann die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
tatsächlich infiziert sind dass der test
also stimmt eigentlich ganz einfach
insgesamt bekommen 980 ein positives
testergebnis nämlich die 800 wirklich
infizierten und die 180
fälschlicherweise positiven 800 von 980
sind 81,6 prozent
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie bei
einem positiven ergebnis tatsächlich
infiziert sind ist also 81,6 prozent
und wenn sie ein negatives testergebnis
haben
wie groß ist dann die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie trotzdem infiziert sind nun
insgesamt bekommen 9020 menschen ein
negatives ergebnis nämlich die 8820
wirklich negativen aber auch die 200
fälschlicherweise negativen 200 von
insgesamt 9 1020 sind 2,2 prozent die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie bei einem
negativen ergebnis in wirklichkeit doch
infiziert sind ist 22 das klingt ja noch
nicht mal so schlecht wenngleich in
unserem beispiel 200 übersehene
infizierte auch ein ganz schönes problem
werden können wenn sie sich nämlich
nicht an die maßnahmen halten weil sie
sich dann in falscher sicherheit wiegen
und dadurch andere an
aber jetzt schauen wir uns das ganze mal
an in einer situation die viel eher der
unseren realen gleich nämlich szenario 2
da sind nicht 1000 von den 10.000
tatsächlich infiziert sondern viel viel
weniger sagen wir fünf von den 10.000
das kommt der situation zum beispiel
testen von irgendwelchen menschen in
einer fußgängerzone sehr nahe und wenn
sich einfach jeder egal ob er symptome
hat oder nicht zum beispiel zuhause
testet von den 10.000 sind also fünf
infiziert 9995 sind es nicht die
sensitivität beträgt nach wie vor 80
prozent das heißt 80 prozent von den
fünf infizierten werden auch richtig
erkannt also vier insgesamt 20 prozent
davon also einer wird nicht erkannt ist
also falsch negativ die spezifität ist
nach wie vor 98 prozent das heißt von
den neun 1995 nicht infizierten werden
98 prozent also neun 1795 richtig als
nicht infiziert erkannt aber zwei
prozent davon also 200 menschen bekommen
ein falsch positives ergebnis insgesamt
folgt daraus dass sie wenn sie ein
negatives testergebnis haben ziemlich
sicher zumindest gerade in diesem moment
auch wirklich negativ sind
[Musik]
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie trotzdem
infiziert sind liegt nur bei 0,01
prozent aber andersherum wenn sie
positiv getestet werden ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie wirklich
positiv sind verschwindend gering denn
insgesamt bekommen ja 200 und 4 ein
positives ergebnis wobei aber nur vier
tatsächlich infiziert sind das
entspricht gerade mal zwei prozent
anders ausgedrückt 98 prozent der
positiv getesteten sind falsch was
lernen wir also daraus die angabe dieser
oder jener test hat eine sensitivität
von sohn zu viel prozent und eine
spezifität von sohn so viel sagt nichts
über die richtigkeit des einzelnen
testergebnis aus entscheidend hierfür
ist ob sie den test in einer gruppe von
menschen machen in der es sehr viele
oder nur ganz wenige infektionen gibt
gibt es nur ganz wenige infektionen
haben sie eine sehr hohe rate an
fehlalarm
und wenn sie jetzt einfach nur diesen
letzten satz verstanden haben oder
meinetwegen sich auch einfach nur merken
ob ein testergebnis stimmt oder nicht
hat viel damit zu tun wie oft die
getestete krankheit oder hier die
infektion überhaupt vorkommt dann wissen
sie mehr und haben mehr verstanden als
die große mehrheit der ärzte
untersuchungen haben nämlich immer
wieder ergeben dass die meisten
mediziner diesen zusammenhang nicht
verstehen denn dieser zusammenhang gilt
natürlich nicht nur für ein crooner test
sondern für alle tests auch für die
vorsorge und
früherkennungsuntersuchungen das macht
diese tests nicht generell schlecht man
sollte das aber im hinterkopf behalten
vielleicht sagen sie jetzt ja auch naja
98% fehlalarme es ist ja nicht ganz so
schlimm besser viele fehlalarme als
übersehene infektionen ja könnte man so
sehen aber leider sagen auch die richtig
negativen tests nur aus dass sie im
moment des
keine oder so gut wie keine viren im
rachen oder in der nase hatten dass der
test nicht ansprang und auch nur richtig
ist wenn sie den test genau nach
vorschrift gemacht haben
der gleiche test nur ein paar stunden
später gemacht könnte schon ein anderes
ergebnis liefern
wenn sie sich dann also in falscher
sicherheit wiegen ich bin ja nicht
infiziert und die schutzmaßnahmen
vernachlässigen
dann könnten sie trotz richtig negativen
test zum super spender werden
andersherum wenn sie positiv getestet
werden
sind sie vielleicht wirklich infiziert
leicht aber auch nicht auf jeden fall
sollten sie sich dann ab sofort wie ein
infizierter verhalten also isolieren und
unbedingt einen pcr test machen lassen
um das ergebnis zu bestätigen ja ich bin
wirklich infiziert oder nein war
falscher alarm der großflächige einsatz
von antigen schnelltest kann also ein
baustein zur rückkehr in die normalität
sein
man muss aber wissen weder sagt ein
negatives testergebnis sicher aus dass
man nicht infiziert ist und niemanden
anstecken kann noch bedeutet ein
positiver test immer infektionen
deshalb bleiben die wichtigsten
maßnahmen kontakte reduzieren abstand
halten und in bestimmten situationen
maske tragen und lüften so oft es geht